[Applaus]
[Musik]
seit im Februar 2022 der russisch
ukrainischen Krieg ausgebrochen ist
versuchen Analysten wie verrückt
vorherzusagen was passieren wird wenn
der Konflikt vorbei ist wann auch immer
dieser Tag kommen mag und aufgepasst
einige haben sogar vorher gesagt dass
das Zerfall Russlands als
zusammenhängender Staat bevorstehen
könnte okay viele dieser Theorien sind
vielleicht der reine Propaganda extreme
Meinungen oder dienen unter Umständen
bestimmten Interessen aber sie klingen
trotzdem interessant und was uns hier
auf visualpolitik sicherlich am meisten
interessiert viele ihre Argumente und
vor allem viele der angeführten riesigen
sind durchaus real schließlich hat Putin
seine Macht vor allem auf drei Säulen
aufgebaut Stärke Geld und Angst oder
anders ausgedrückt Image Zuckerbrot und
Peitsche mit Hilfe dieser drei
Prinzipien hält er alle für ihn
notwendigen Gruppen in Schach und sich
gewogen der Bevölkerung imponiert er als
starker Macho und Siegertyp als
derjenige der ihn nach den erbärmlichen
90er Jahren einigermaßen Wohlstand
brachte und ihn nun auch noch die
nationalistische Herrlichkeit des alten
Imperiums wieder bringen möchte die
Führungseliten des Landes seiner fünften
Kolonne im Ausland was allen Staaten und
ausländische Politiker bindet er mit
üppiger Bestechung aus dem
Rohstoffreichtum des Landes und
militärischer Stärke an sich und all
diese Gruppen behält er fest im Griff
durch Angst vor Kälte und gasmangel
Angst vor seiner Unberechenbarkeit und
Skrupellosigkeit Angst vor der Macht der
russischen Armee und nicht zuletzt Angst
vor dem Atomkrieg
ja als aber Russland in der Ukraine eine
herbe militärische Niederlage einstecken
sollte könnten alle diese drei Säulen
wegsacken Sieger Image und groß macht
Fantasien während da hin vom lieben Geld
lieber auch viel weniger zu verteilen
als vorher und wer bitteschön soll noch
Angst vor der russischen Armee haben
oder auch nur eine Pfifferling auf sie
setzen wollen sogar der jahrzehntelang
im Wasser Armenien will sich nicht mehr
auf deren zweifelh Schutz verlassen und
wendet sich lieber an die NATO aber wozu
ins Ausland schweifen bemerkenswert ist
vor allem die hohe Zahl der potenziellen
Brandherde auf russischem Boden und ihr
geradezu vielfältiger Charakter für all
diese zentrifugalen Kräfte wäre eine
saftige Niederlage Putins in der Ukraine
ein gefundenes Fressen und angesichts
der immer gewagteren Sticheleien der
Ukraine bezüglich ihrer
Frühjahrsoffensive läuft ihnen geradezu
das Wasser im Mund zusammen der
Schlachtruf lautet spring ist der
Frühling kommt aber was für die eine
Seite ein Schlachthof klingt in den
Ohren der Gegenseite wie der reinste
Albtraum der Anfang vom Ende eine
Entwicklung die uns in der nächsten Zeit
sicherlich intensiv beschäftigen wird
und genau deswegen werden wir diesen
Themenkomplex der Balkanisierung und den
möglichen Zerfall der Russischen
Föderation eine ganze Reihe von Videos
mit Mann vergesst also bitte nicht das
Abo und aktiviert auch unbedingt das
Glöckchen um keines davon zu verpassen
heute wollen wir damit anfangen indem
wir uns auf einen Brandherd
konzentrieren der unsere Aufmerksamkeit
auf ganz besondere Weise erregt hat
warum nun weil er eine Frage aufhört die
die meisten von uns wahrscheinlich nie
in Betracht gezogen haben inwieweit
könnte der gerhardismus zum Zerfall
Russland beitragen Bonn ihr fragt euch
sicher was zum Teufel der hatismus mit
Russland zu tun hat Leben wirklich so
viele Muslime in der Russischen
Föderation nun tatsächlich sie tun es
ungefähr zehn Prozent der gesamten
russischen Bevölkerung sind bereits im
Ausland sondern es wird vorher gesagt
dass diese Zahl bis 2030 auf über 20%
einsteigen könnte
zum Vergleich selbst in den am stärksten
islamisierten Ländern Europas wie
Frankreich Belgien Österreich oder
Schweden wird dieser Anteil bis dahin
voraussichtlich auf Werte von knapp über
10% steigen also auf die Hälfte des
russischen und auch in absoluten Zahlen
sprechen wird dort nämlich über eine
mächtige muslimische Bevölkerung welche
die Größe ganzer Länder übertreffen wird
in ein paar Jahren könnte sie durchaus
realistisch über 25 Millionen zählen was
er doppelten Einwohnerzahl Moskau
entspricht die ethnische russische
Bevölkerung hat währenddessen massiv
schrumpfen sei es durch Kinderlosigkeit
ungesunde Lebensführung Krieg oder
Auswanderung daher steht schon heute
fest dass sich die Bevölkerungsstruktur
und damit das Gesicht Russland innerhalb
weniger Jahre stark verändern werden ich
würde also sagen dass dies ein verdammt
wichtiges Thema ist oder was meint ihr
fakt ist der Islam bildet in mehreren
Regionen Russland bereits heute die
mehrheitsreligion seht euch mal diese
Karte an wie ihr hier sehen könnt gibt
es in Russland 7 Gebiete mit
muslimischer Bevölkerungs Mehrheit die
fünf autonomen Republiken des
Nordkaukasus sowie katastram und
basketten in der Wolga Ural Region und
obwohl es in Russland keine offizielle
Staatsreligion als solche gibt das Land
ist auf dem Papier ein säkularer Staat
zieht sich die Religion durch die
gesamte nationale Politik wenn ihr mir
das nicht glauben wolltet frag doch
einfach den materialischen
Oberhaupt erklärt das russische Soldaten
die in der Ukraine Sterben von ihrem
Sünden gereinigt werden
das war nebenbei eine epochale Wende in
der Geschichte der orthodoxen Kirche in
diese hatte ich historisch stets
geweigert eine solche Proklamation zu
machen und zwar selbst als die
byzantinischen Reich Mitte des zehnten
Jahrhunderts der Untergang durch
muslimische also Ungläubige Angreifer
drohte der Patriarch in Moskau hat nun
praktisch den ersten orthodoxen Kreuzzug
ausgerufen und das auch noch
ausgerechnet gegen andere orthodoxe
Christen das muss man sich mal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen aber so
korrumpiert die orthodoxe Kirche in
Russland auch ist das orthodoxe
Christentum bildet nun mal im größten
Teil der Russischen Föderation die
mehrheitsreligion fast 80% der großen
bekennen sich Tochter auch wenn sie ihn
Wahrheit nur von wenigen wirklich
praktiziert wird einigen Daten zufolge
besuchen kommen vier Prozent regelmäßig
einen Gottesdienst andererseits hatte
Einfluss der orthodoxen Kirche in den
letzten Jahren insbesondere dank einer
eifrigen Förderung durch Wladimir Putin
merklich zugenommen wir stehen erst am
Anfang der geistigen wiedergeboren
aber lasst uns in die jene sieben
Regionen Russland zurückkehren in denen
Muslime die Mehrheit stellen in diesen
ist nämlich teilweise die Scharia das
Gebot der Stunde vor allem in den
Republiken des Nordkaukasus ihr wollt
ein Beispiel nun sagen wir einfach dass
ihr in Tschetschenien besser nicht dabei
erwischt werden sollte wenn ihr euch mit
jemandem gleichen Geschlechts abgebt
denn nun ja sie werden euch dafür
entweder zu todeprügeln oder direkt in
ein Konzentrationslager schicken ganz
genau so verfärbt man mit homosexuell in
diesen Teil der Welt schon vor einiger
Zeit haben sich viele Moscheen in dieser
Region der Radikalisierung möglichst
viele Gemeinde Mitglieder verschrieben
um den Journalismus in Tschetschenien
Tagesgeschehen und allen muslimischen
Regionen Russlands im Allgemeinen so
fördern nach all dem stellt sich daher
die Frage inwieweit könnte der die
hatismus zu einem echten Problem für
Moskau werden wie haben sich diese
Gruppen in Russland bisher entwickelt
kommt es in Russland viel eher zum
befürchteten clash of cultures als in
Europa in die weit sprechende über einen
bevor mit denen Konflikt der sogar
situationsbestrebungen führen könnte in
diesem Video werden wir natürlich all
diese Fragen und noch einige mehr
beantworten und zwar wie so oft gleich
nach einem kurzen und knackigen
Werbehinweis unseres tollen Sponsors
surfshark denn surfshark hat nicht nur
das heutige Video möglich gemacht nein
es hat auch noch ein VPN im Angebot das
wirklich empfehlenswert und vor allem
sicher und vertrauenswürdig ist so lockt
es zum Beispiel selbstverständlich
keinerlei Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich
kann einen Virtual Private nett vor
allem Gefahren man muss nach wie vor
Umsicht walten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hier für ein Werkzeug
mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist in Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen im
letzten nachzufolgen und abzuhören mit
Hilfe verschiedener Sicherheit Features
könnt ihr so eine Anonymität erhöhen z.B
mit dem integrierten Team wird das alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Popups blockt
weiterer Vorteile eines dass ihr so tun
könnt als wärt ihr an einem anderen Ort
so könnt ihr zum Beispiel auch Webseite
und Internetdienste zugreifen in dem
Land das hat nicht verfügbar werden oder
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sind so
deswegen ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
andere Streamingdienste die Reden von
Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshark kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles damit nur eins für
Konto könnte wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte im VPN registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
angeht bekommt ihr von surfshark auch
noch einen Rabatt in Höhe von 83% und
obendrein die ersten drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nichts besorgt euch schon
gerade damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnte
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links den ich euch ebenfalls in
die Video Beschreibung gepackt habe wir
sind euch für jede Unterstützung dankbar
denn damit hättet ihr uns euch in
Zukunft noch mehr und noch bessere
Videos zu liefern so und nun lasst uns
schnell in die Geschichte des Kaukasus
eintauchen um folgende Fragen zu
beantworten in welchem Ausmaß besteht
die Möglichkeit dass der internenismus
für Russland zu einer ernsthaften
Herausforderung wird was ist die
Geschichte der verschiedenen Gruppen
könnte Russland in einem Kulturkonflikt
ger aten der viel stärker als in Europa
ausfällt steht dem Riesenreich einen
Religionskonflikt bevor der Separatismus
führen könnte auf geht's
[Musik]
das Kaukasus Emirat
ich bin mir sicher dass wir alle mehr
oder weniger die Geschichte von da
echtes selbst ernannten und sogenannten
islamischen Staates kennen Jahre lang
bombardierten uns die Medien mit
Nachrichten über seine militärischen
Vorstöße und Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit in Syrien und im Irak
aber ich bin sicher dass schon deutlich
weniger von euch wissen dass Russland
auf seinem eigenen Territorium mit einer
jihadistischen Bewegung konfrontiert war
die der das islamischen Staates ähnelte
ja tatsächlich wir sprechen über das
Kaukasus Emirat okay es stimmt das
dieses nicht so groß war und nicht so
viel Einfluss auf Russland gewinnen
konnte wie es dem islamischen Staat im
Nahen Osten gelangen aber es hat Putin
trotzdem so einige Kopfschmerzen
bereitet bedenkt bitte das wenn dieses
Emirat ein Staat geworden wäre es
territorial und nach Bevölkerungszahl
größer als Georgien Armenien und
Aserbaidschan gewesen wäre aber die
Frage ist natürlich ob der Islam in
Russland genügend Bedeutung besitzt das
ein paar radikale so weit gehen würden
ihr eigenes Emirat zu gründen nun die
kurze Antwort darauf lautet ja der Islam
ist sicherlich bedeutender als ihr denkt
der Islam kam bereits im siebten
Jahrhundert auf das Gebiet des heutigen
Russlands und bereitete sich über den
Kaukasus aus seitdem gewann der Glaube
Mohammed in dagestanen immer mehr an
Stärke bis er zur mehrheitsreligion in
der gesamten Region wurde natürlich war
dies kein einfacher Prozess sondern
wurde von mehreren repressionskampagnen
gegen die muslimische Bevölkerung und
Kaukasus und auch gegen die muslimischen
Tataren im Volker oral-gebiet und auf
der Krim begleitet von IBAN dem
schrecklichen im 16 Jahrhundert bis zur
Sowjetunion wurde der muslimische Glaube
im heutigen Russland über lange
Zeiträume hinweg hart unterdrückt die
Zahlung sahen Minderheiten mit eigenen
Ansichten im Allgemeinen als Gefahr und
die somit Union war wie er sicherlich
wisst anstrengen atheistischer Staat mit
dem Zerfall das wird Union kehrte jedoch
die religiöse Freiheit zurück und mit
ihr auch das wieder aufleben des Islams
in Russland zudem wurden muslimische
Einrichtungen wie die Union der Muslime
Russlands und zahlreiche Koran Schulen
und islamisch Universitäten wie die
islamische Universität dagegen gegründet
der Islam ist sogar so wichtig dass ein
gesetzlich als eine der vier Tradition
Ellen Religion des Landes anerkannt ist
und wie ich bereits erwähnt habe
beginnen sich 10% der Gesamtbevölkerung
des Landes also etwa 15 Millionen
Menschen zu diesem Glauben der
springende Punkt ist jedoch das ist sich
dabei um eine relativ junge Bevölkerung
mit vielen Kindern handelt es hat ihr
Einfluss beständig zunimmt
und okay es stimmt nur weil es in einem
Land eine einigermaßen große muslimische
Bevölkerung gibt heißt das nicht dass es
per se Probleme mit radikalen
Gruppierungen geben muss aber auch wenn
dies nicht immer der Fall ist du scheint
es doch in Russland der Fall gewesen zu
sein
[Musik]
tatsächlich ist das Kaukasus nichts
anderes als das Erbe der
Auseinandersetzungen und der beiden
blutigen Kriege zwischen Russland und
Tschechien die seine frühere 90er Jahren
bis weit ins dritte Jahr 1.000
hingeführt wurden wie viele von euch
wahrscheinlich wissen Sie die Spannungen
zwischen Russland und Tschechien seit
jeher sehr hoch schon im zaristischen
Ausland kämpften die Waffengewalt gegen
Virus um ihre Unabhängigkeit zu erlangen
während
einer einzigen Republik vereinigt deren
Bewohner verstanden sie sogar so
schlecht mit den Russen dass sie die
Invasion der Nazis soweit ausnutzten und
an ihrer Seite kämpften um ihre
Unabhängigkeit zu erlangen eine
Kooperation die nach den Rückzug der
Wehrmacht durch die wir jetzt mit einer
Deportation von mehr als eine halbe
Million Menschen bestraft wurde und als
sie Sowjetunion 1991 schließlich
zusammenbrach erklärte sich
Tschetschenien für unabhängig die Viren
im Land waren aber so groß dass Moskau
erst 1984 mit voller Wucht reagierte und
von da an hielt es bis 2002 eine blutige
militärische Operation in Tschetschenien
aufrecht die den Konflikt schließlich
offiziell beendete auch wenn der
Widerstand danach noch ein paar Jahre
vor sich hin dümpelte allerdings stellte
dieser teure Sieg über die
Aufständischen einen echten
Popularitätsschub für den neuen
russischen Präsidenten da Putin baute
einen beträchtlichen Teil seiner
Karriere auf dem Krieg schon als
Premierminister auf und nachdem sich
seine Truppen durchgesetzt haben konnte
er endlich aufatmen die Terroranschläge
ließen schließlich merklich nach unter
dem wachsamen Auge des Vaters unseres
alten Bekannten Ramiro wir haben über
das Thema Tschetschenien schon ein
eigenes Video gedreht und ich werde es
euch verlinken was Putin jedoch nicht
ahnte war die Tatsache dass er obwohl er
die Tür zum chinesischen Separatismus
geschlossen hatte automatisch einen
großes Fenster für den gerhardistischen
ter rorismus öffnet und dieses Fenster
führte dazu dass der chemisches
Separatisten für Dr omaro im Jahr 2007
das Kaukasus Emirat Ausrede hat gegen
Russland begann aber ihr fragt euch
jetzt vielleicht was genau war
eigentlich dieses Kaukasus Emirat
nun im Grunde ist es das Projekt eines
neuen unabhängigen Staates der von der
Scharia regiert wird und den gesamten
Nordkaukasus besetzt das heißt nicht nur
die autonomen Republiken der Region
bicycinien da gestern und rochet sind
sondern das gesamte Gebiet von Dagestan
bis zum Asowschen Meer und ich bin mir
sicher dass viele von euch denken dass
Tschetschenien der wichtigste Teil
dieses neuen Emirates war oder nun
falsch gedacht es war da gestern
vogelabschoss die tschetschenischen
Dschihadisten belügten sich nicht damit
in Russland zu bleiben und begannen sich
in der ganzen Region auszubreiten der
Emil der den nachfolgung Maros Antrag
war sogar ein dageistani ein weiterer
Beweis dafür dass da gestern zum API
Zentrum des Realismus in der Region
wurde ist die Tatsache dass es genau die
Region mit den meisten opfernalistischer
Terroranschläge war Tschetschenien lag
also nur auf dem zweiten Platz dieser
unrühmlichen Rangliste aber wer sind
eigentlich die Gruppen hinter dem Rad
wie groß ist ihr Einfluss in der Region
wirklich welche Gefahr geht von ihnen
aus und wie viele Muslime der Region
sind tatsächlich Unterstützer dieser
Vorgehensweise gegen Moskau lasst uns
das alles lieber mal etwas genauer unter
die Lupe nehmen aufgepasst
versus
wissen genau das ist nicht einfach ist
die Unterschiede zwischen den
verschiedenen Zweigen ein und derselben
Religion zu erklären um das Problem des
Journalismus zu verstehen muss man aber
den wichtigsten Unterschiede kennen aber
halten wir es einfach wir haben schon
das ein oder andere mal darüber
gesprochen der Islam ist im Grunde in
zwei große Familien geteilt die Sunniten
und die skiäten diese Spaltung geht auf
die Zeit kurz nach dem toten Mohammeds
im Jahr 632 nach Christus zurück einige
Muslime glaubten dass die Kalifen die
Nachfolger des Propheten sein sollten
angefangen mit Mohammed Cousin und
Schwiegersohn
diese waren und sind die Schiiten die
aufgrund des erblichen Charakters ihrer
Führung eine Hierarchie aufrecht
erhalten die ja toll das angeführt wird
und viel zentrale und einflussreicher
ist auf der anderen Seite gab es die
Muslime die nicht glaubten das Mohammed
direkte religiöse Nachkommen
hinterlassen hatte und das daher die
geistlichen Führer von der Gemeinschaft
gewählt werden mussten sie bildeten die
Sunniten deren Organisation weitgehend
dezentralisiert ist ihr seht also
zwischen den Schiiten und Sony gibt es
schon grundsätzliche organisatorische
und philosophische Unterschiede aber gut
kommen wir nach Russland zurück dort
sind die fast überall auf der Welt die
Sunniten in der Mehrheit aber passt
jetzt gut auf denn innerhalb des
sunnitentums gibt es weitere Spaltungen
und die die uns am meisten interessiert
ist die in Nordkaukasus zu stehen zu
wissen und Salafisten okay ihr denkt
jetzt vielleicht wenn beide aus
demselben muslimischen Zweig stammen
werden sie doch nicht allzu viele
Differenzen haben oder nun ja nichts
könnte weiter von der Wahrheit entfernt
sein
[Musik]
man könnte sagen dass der zugfest muss
in der gesamten muslimischen Welt
generell eine Minderheit darstellt
anders als die politische Mehrheit liegt
er den Schwerpunkt nicht auf die
Reinheit der religiösen Riten sondern
vor allem auf das spirituelle Leben mit
anderen Worten sie suchen eine mystische
Beziehung zu Allah auf einer sehr
individuellen Ebene wobei sie natürlich
immer die Grund weil er das Islam
respektieren der Salafismus hingegen ist
viel viel fundamentalistischer
der traditionalistische Salafismus
konzentriert sich neben der Reinheit der
Lehrer auf die Predigt um den Glauben zu
stärken den Zusammenhalt der
Gemeinschaft zu bewahren und die
islamische moralordnung zu verteidigen
einen Diskurs der einen Bruch mit den er
lauwarmen Muslimen darstellt
[Musik]
diese beiden Strömungen unterscheiden
sich jedoch nicht nur durch ihre mehr
oder weniger individualistische oder
kollektivistische Sichtweise die
Salafisten lehnt zum Beispiel Innovation
im Islam grundsätzlich ab weil sie sie
als Abweichung von dem von Allah
vorgezeichneten Weg betrachten ihr Ziel
ist es die ursprüngliche Praxis des
Islam wiederherzustellen indem sie den
Einfluss von lokaler Kultur und
Tradition ablehnen und unterdrücken so
wie es hingegen tolerieren und fördern
Neuerungen und externe bzw lokale
Einflüsse sie haben sogar ihre eigenen
heiligen was die Salafisten natürlich
vollkommen ablehnen der wichtigste
Unterschied ist jedoch ihre Haltung zum
dschi hat die Salafisten befürworten ihn
natürlich in hohem Maße wären die zu
fies viel gemäßigter sind
wie also seht können wir auf keinen Fall
sagen dass zu wissen muss und Salafismus
die Zwillinge sind auch wenn die Wörter
ehrlich klingen daher ist es nicht
verwunderlich dass überall dort wo sich
ihre Wege kreuzen Spannungen und
Konflikte zwischen den beiden Fraktionen
entstehen und genau das ist im
Nordkaukasus der Fall
der Sufismus ist hier gut etabliert und
ist der zweite ist Islam der
logischerweise von Moskau unterstützt
wird trotzdem ist es so dass der
Salafismus seitdem Kriegen in
Tschetschenien ein Stärke gewonnen hat
und Schätzungen zufolge bis zu 700.000
Muslime in Russland diese Überzeugung
angenommen haben seine globale
Ausbreitung begann erst in den 1970er
Jahren und zwar dann großer Geldmengen
aus Saudi-Arabien wie viele Bau
salafistischer Moscheen auf der ganzen
Welt verantwortlich sind daher ist es
nicht überraschend dass viele dieser
Moscheen nicht nur grundlegende
unschuldige Gottesdienste abhielten
sondern auch als Zentren der
Radikalisierung dienten und wie wir uns
alle vorstellen können ist es umso
leichter den Glauben zu radikalisieren
hier schlechter die Lebensbedingungen
vor Ort sind und genau aus diesem Grund
ist der salatismus im nordkorso beliebt
die dortigen autonomen Republiken weisen
die schlechtesten Wirtschaftsdaten der
gesamten russischen Föderation auf
Englisch sind zum Beispiel damit 30% die
höchste Arbeitslosenquote im Reich und
die Armutsquote in
liegt bei sage und schreibe 25% schaut
euch mal diese Tabelle an
[Musik]
wie ihr hier sehen könnt gehören die
fünf autonomen Republiken des russischen
Kaukasus zu den 10 ärmsten Regionen im
ganzen Land und dümpeln auf dem Niveau
klassischer in totaler Armut
abgestürzter fails States herum wie
Haiti Afghanistan oder Uganda im
kaukasischen Teil Russland stehen somit
die unrühmlichsten Leuchttürme der
ungeheuren Ungleichverteilung von
Wohlstand in rohstoffreichsten Land der
Erde damit ihr euch ein Bild machen
könnt und 500 Superreiche Russen 500
Einzelpersonen kontrollieren mehr
Vermögen als die Ärmsten 99,8 % der
Bevölkerung an eine derart krasse
Ungleichheit kommt weil ich kein anderes
Land heran die reichsten 500 die weniger
als 0,001 Prozent der russischen
Bevölkerung ausmachen sitzen mehr als
die Ärmsten 115 Millionen der
erwachsenen Bevölkerung und von diesem
Leben verdammt viele im Nordkaukasus und
ich persönlich frage mich angesichts
dieser Faktenlage immer wieder wieso
sich noch irgendjemand in Europa gerade
von jedem Politikern und Multi Faktoren
und Putins Wagen spannen lässt die an
der mindesten wahlweise vorgeben große
Kämpfer für soziale Gerechtigkeit oder
das Vaterland zu sein oder
garantiekapitalisten sie tadeln sich
dabei als Linke die angeblich schwache
beschützen oder rechte die so tun als
würden sie die Interessen ihrer eigenen
Nation vertreten doch in Wirklichkeit
singen sie nur die Musik desjenigen der
zahlt sie tackern und köppeln brav im
Takt des Kremls um die verführten
Gehirne ihrer Anhänger zu knechten und
was im europäischen oder amerikanischen
Ausland gut funktioniert geht im
russischen Inland natürlich noch besser
der unvorstellbar gigantische Diebstahl
des russischen Volksvermögens läuft so
geschmiert wie nie zuvor von den aber
Milliarden die nach Russland durch den
Rohstoff Export fließen kommen keine
nennenswerten Beträge bei der Mehrheit
der Menschen an stattdessen werden sie
gezielt mit den Lügen abgespeist die sie
gerne hören möchten und finanziell mit
jedem absoluten Minimum damit sie gerade
mal nicht zu sehr aufmucken und falls
Sie das doch tun werden sie eben
niedergeknüppel weg der vertrieben
vergiftet oder gleich weggebombt so wie
damals die Tschetschenen das Ergebnis
bringt die Hälfte der russischen
Familien verfügen gerade mal über ein
Einkommen mit dem sie ihren Hunger
stillen und sich einigermaßen ordentlich
anziehen können zwei Drittel aller
Haushalte könnten sich noch nicht einmal
eine neue Waschmaschine leisten 40% der
Familien mit mehreren Kindern verfügen
über keinen kanalisationsanschluss und
während zum Beispiel im Jahr 2020 das
verfügbare real-einkommen der Russen um
3,6% sank schnellte der Reichtum der
Oligarchen und sagenhafte 45% in die
Höhe ja genau während nur eines Jahres
das meine Lieben Zuschauer ist das
System Putin das wohl asozialste
Wirtschaftssystem der Welt und natürlich
ist eine derartige Ungleichheit Inhalt
eines einzigen Staatswesens der perfekte
soziale Sprengstoff einer der umso
unerwartete explodieren wird je länger
und stärker man ihn mit physischer und
psychischer Gewalt unterdrückt aber
natürlich ist man im Kreml nicht blöd
man ist sich dieser Probleme bewusst und
man ist sich auch dessen bewusst dass
man für deren Lösung über einen
Jahrhunderte alten Werkzeugkasten
verfügt einen Werkzeugkasten mit dem
schon die Zaren das russische
Kolonialreich geschaffen und beherrscht
haben und das bewerteste Instrument
darin heißt natürlich teile und herrsche
wollt ihr wissen die Putin dieses
Instrument mit bisher großen Erfolg zum
Einsatz bringt dann passt jetzt gut auf
Gegengift gegen Salafismus
der Kampf zwischen Sufismus und
Salafismus findet nicht nur im Kaukasus
statt etwas ganz Ähnliches finden wir
auch in Afrika allein in Ghana haben
salafistische NGOs zwischen den Jahren
2010 91 Moscheen und 89 Religionsschulen
gebaut und auf dem gesamten
afrikanischen Kontinent hat die
kroatische Africa Muslims agency
geschätzt das in den letzten 35 Jahren
6000 Moscheen und 800 Religionsschulen
oder Bildungszentren von Salafisten
gebaut worden wir sprechen also von
einem Kampf zwischen Sufismus und
Salafismus der wahrlich globaler Natur
ist in Russland hat sich Moskau
entschieden sich mit dem Sufismus zu
verbinden um den dschihadistischen
Salafismus zu bekämpfen und um die
Wahrheit zu sagen bisher fahren Sie
damit ziemlich erfolgreich die wir
bereits gesehen haben wurde Religionen
nach den Zerfall das so wird Union
wieder ein Teil der russischen
Gesellschaft aber natürlich sind dabei
nicht alle Religionen gleich behandelt
worden tatsächlich hat das orthodoxe
Christentum überaus stark von dieser
neuen esoterisch klerikalen Renaissance
profitiert während der resteuropas die
Beziehungen zwischen Staat und Klerus
zunehmend trennte hat Russland die
orthodoxe Kirche großzügig finanziert
ihr alle möglichen Privilegien
eingeräumt ihr erlaubt ihre Religion in
den Schulen zu unterrichten die Gesetze
maßgeblich zu beeinflussen und natürlich
so viele Kirchen zu bauen wie sie will
und das stellt natürlich ein weiteres
klares Potenzial für Spannungen mit der
muslimischen Gemeinschaft des Landes da
muss kosmoslems finden keinen Platz in
der Moschee während es z.B alleine in
Moskau 600 öffentliche orthodoxe Kirchen
gibt gibt es dort nur eine Handvoll
öffentlicher Moscheen zu denen die
geschätzten 2 bis 4 Millionen Moslems in
Moskau freien Zugang haben es überrascht
daher nicht dass bei all diesen
Privilegien der Nährboden für
Radikalismus mehr als reif ist aber
Putin weiß das und deshalb hat er sich
auch gemäß einem bewährten Zuckerbrot
und falsche Prinzip bemüht gute
Beziehung zu den russischen Muslimen zu
pflegen sagen wir es so die
Unterstützung des institutionalisierten
Islams insbesondere das zu viel Islams
im Kaukasus ist der Weg mit den er den
dschihadistischen Salafismus bekämpfen
will
[Musik]
Moskau unterstützen Islam durch drei
Institutionen den russischen Rat der
muft dies den Zentralrat der
muslimischen Kleriker und das
Koordinationszentrum der Muslime im
Nordkaukasus wichtig ist dabei jedoch
die selektive Lenkungsfunktion der
Ressourcenverteilung denn wenn
muslimische Organisationen im Land oder
den autonomen Republiken des Kaukasus
öffentliche Geld erfunden diesen
Institution erhalten wollen ist ihnen
nicht gerade Salafisten zu sein darüber
hinaus hat sich Moskau auch auf die
Verbreitung des so viel Islam
konzentriert sowohl in Schulen als auch
in Zentren für die Umerziehung
ehemaliger Journalisten was aufgrund der
Anziehungskraft der Salafismus für die
junge Generation besonders wichtig ist
die größte Wirkung auf den Salafismus im
Kopf also es haben jedoch direktem
Maßnahmen gehabt das heißt militärische
Aktionen
nachdem Moskau Ende der 1990er Jahren zu
Beginn des neuen Jahrtausends eine Reihe
von Gesetzen über religiöse
Vereinigungen und den Kampf gegen
terroristische Aktivitäten verabschiedet
hatte wurden die Ärmel hochgekrempelt
der Salafismus wurde aktiv bekämpft
sowohl mit den russischen Streitkräften
die zumindest bis zum Beginn des
kriegesinn Ukraine und 80.000 Soldaten
in der Region stationiert hatten als
auch mit den Armen von Putins handlang
an wie zum Beispiel kadeoff selbst und
das zeigte der Wirkung der Dschihadismus
hat an Stärke verloren tatsächlich haben
moskausdruck und Absprachen mit vielen
lokalen Anführern dazu geführt dass die
Bevölkerung des Kaukasus selbst in den
Kampf gegen den Journalismus einbezogen
wurde und wenn ihr mir das jetzt nicht
glaubt fragt einfach die chemischen
Frauen
Frauen [__] den islamischen Staat und
erbeuten Tausende von Dollars indem sie
sich als potentielle bereute ausgeben
drei junge tschetschenische frauen sind
in Schwierigkeiten nachdem sie dabei
erwischt wurden wie sie Kämpfer des
islamischen Staates um Tausende von
Dollar betrogen haben indem sie sich als
möchtegern siehadisten wollte Ausgaben
Berichten zufolge werden die Frauen
jetzt von klassischen Behörden wegen des
Verdachts auch Betrug festgehalten okay
dabei handelt es sich eher um eine
kuriose Anekdote aber immerhin geht es
darum Jihadisten ihr Geld abzuluchsen
also hut ab schließlich ist es wieder
mal der schöne Mammon der auch an dieser
Stelle das Zünglein an der Waage ist das
Versiegen seiner Finanzströme hat
nämlich dazu geführt dass der russische
jihadismus ein Schwung verloren hat denn
mit der Entstehung von da echt der
sogenannten islamischen Staates in
Syrien und den Irak ist das meiste Geld
des globalen sie hat dorthin und im
Kaukasus Emirat gingen dann sowohl das
Geld als auch die Kämpfer aus so wie die
Dinge liegen ist das Kaukasus Emirat der
größte Vertreter die hatistisch
salafistischer Bestrebungen Russland
2016 effektiv verschwunden
[Musik]
das heißt aber nicht dass der Salafismus
als solche verschwunden ist in der Tat
ist er bei kaukasischen Jugendlichen
nach wie vor äußerst beliebt weil er ihn
in einer Region in der es kommt
Perspektiven und Aufstiegschancen für
sie gibt einen Ausweg bietet und nicht
nur für Kaukasier auch in katastran
einer anderen autonomen Republik
innerhalb Russlands im Wolga uralgebiet
gibt es dschihadistische Gruppen einige
von ihnen sind sogar in Nachrichten wie
dieser aufgetaucht russische
moslemführer in katastran angegriffen im
allgemeinen kann man jedoch sagen dass
es Russland bisher gelungen ist die
Welle designalistischen Terrorismus die
das Land und in nordkorca zu den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten heimsucht hatte
einzudämmen das geradistische
separatistenprojekt des Kaukasus
scheiterte an der eisernen Faust Putins
und seiner satraten die Theorien über
abspaltungsbestrebungen aus dem
islamischen Russland den Zuge des
Krieges in der Ukraine aufkamen könnten
also übertrieben sein zumindest im
Augenblick denn unter dem Deckel brodelt
es nach wie vor mehr denn je gilt
aufgeschoben heißt nicht aufgehoben
und in Zukunft könnten die Probleme noch
wesentlich größer anschwellen und
schwerer zu beherrschen sein als früher
die Saat für die kommenden Konflikte ist
gesät und sie bekommt gerade jetzt ihren
besten Dünger denn zur eindeutigen
demografischen Entwicklung und der
Tatsache dass die Ideen der Salafisten
keineswegs aus dem Köpfen der Menschen
vor allem den der Jugendlichen
verschwunden sind gesellen sich nun
einige hoch explosive Zutaten wenn sich
die Lage in Russland weiter
verschlechtert wie Sanktionen die
Wirtschaft beeinträchtigen und immer
mehr junge Menschen an der von sterben
könnte dass der perfekte KICKPUNKT für
eine Rückkehr nicht nur Salafismus
sondern auch der abspaltungsbestrebungen
in muslimischen Russland sein
insbesondere aufgrund des Verdachts dass
die russischen Streitkräfte bevorzugt
nationale Minderheiten für den
Fleischwolf in der Ukraine einziehen
also auch Muslime Putin versucht mit
dieser Strategie nämlich zwei Fliegen
mit einer Klappe zu schlagen einerseits
sieht die Arme und ungebildete Jugend im
Militärdienst auf den einzigen Ausweg
aus ihrer Perspektivlosigkeit vor Ort
und andererseits hoffte ausgerechnet auf
diese Weise etwas Dampf aus dem
demografischen Kessel zu lassen das
Zahlenverhältnis zwischen ethnischen
großen und noch Minderheiten etwas zu
drehen indem man die Jugend der
letzteren an der Front verheizt während
die ersteren in den reichen Großstädten
studieren können ob dieses zynische und
rassistische Experiment jedoch aufgeht
steht in den Sternen schließlich hat
Putin in der Ukraine bewiesen dass er
längst das Gespür für die Stimmung in
Ethnien und Gesellschaften außerhalb
seines direkten macht Zugriffs verloren
hat und so wie er dachte die Ukraine
würden dankbar in seiner Arme laufen
könnte er sich auch mit den Muslimen
verrechnet haben die Geschichte lehrt
uns ja sowieso das ist nicht so einfach
ist weitgehend islamische Gebiete unter
der Kontrolle eines Staates zu halten
der zunehmend mit einer anderen Religion
in diesem Fall im orthodoxen Christen
verbunden ist und erst recht wenn sich
der Eindruck verfestigt dass die
muslimische Bevölkerung nur dazu
missbraucht wird an der Front gegen den
anderen zu unterjochen das Volk zu
kämpfen das zwar Putin gerne
kolonisieren würde so wie sie vormals
von den Russen kolonisiert wurden aus
diesem Grund kämpfen in der Ukraine von
Anfang an auch zahlreiche Schäden wie
auch Angehörige viele andere durch die
Russen unterdrückter
[Musik]
weiß dass sie nach einem Sieg der
Ukraine der militärischen Niederlage
Russlands und erst recht wenn er nicht
mehr an der Macht sein sollte in ihrer
Heimat zurückkehren und dort den Keim
eines neuen Widerstands bilden werden
auch dies ist ein Grund neben vielen
anderen wieso Putin jetzt den Krieg in
die Ukraine unendlich in die Länge
ziehen muss und Friedensverhandlungen
immer nur zum Schein führen wird er
hatte sich selbst untrennbar mit diesen
Krieg verbunden es geht schlicht und
einfach um seinen macht er halt und sein
eigenes Überleben damit aber wird das
unter der Oberfläche Anschwellen der
revolutionäre Potenzial zur totalen
Balkanisierung der Russischen Föderation
nur noch größer werden wie gesagt
aufgeschoben heißt nicht aufgehoben und
deswegen meine Lieben besorgen Politik
Zuschauer werden wir schon sehr bald
eine Fortsetzung zu diesem Video
herausbringen um euch die weiteren
kritischen Schwachstellen vorzustellen
mit denen Russland in den kommenden
Jahren oder sogar Jahrzehnten
konfrontiert werden wird eine arme junge
Bevölkerung von mehr als 25 Millionen
Muslimen mit einer kulturellen und
religiösen Identität die sich so sehr
von der moskauz unterscheidet ist eine
gewaltige tickende Zeitbombe aber eben
nicht die einzige inputinsreich also
vergesst bitte nicht das Abo und
aktiviert auch unbedingt das Glöckchen
falls euch dieses Thema genauso stark
interessiert wie uns und nachdem ihr das
erledigt habt könnt ihr gleich in die
Kommentare abtauchen glaubt ihr das
Russland Strategie zur Eindämmung von
Dschihadismus und Salafismus auf der
ganzen Welt nachgeahmt werden könnte ist
der Dschihadismus ein schlafende Riese
der jeden Moment erwachen und Chaos in
ganz Russland auslösen könnte könnte ein
nahe Zukunft zum Aufstieg von
separatistischen Bewegungen führen was
wird mit Russland passieren wenn es den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine verliert und was
wenn Putin nicht mehr im Kreml sitzen
wird wie immer sind doch Organisation zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein
Like und teilt dieses Video mit euren
Freunden um es mit ihnen zu diskutieren
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch mit uns dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]